nevada's test positivity rate does
continue to break records good evening
to you thank you for joining us at five
i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez the state is
reporting now a
record high of 21.2 percent
positivity today as hospitalizations
also continue to rise
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
joining us now live in the newsroom
after listening to the call earlier
today kristin
denise and brian the search continues
across the state and it's not likely to
stop
soon there are 16 of 17 counties flagged
for elevated disease transmission
including here in clark county the state
says it continues to monitor
thanksgiving exposures
that will likely become part of the data
starting this week so
adding a surge on top of a surge the
state is reporting 1767 people are in
the hospital today
with confirmed or suspected cases of
coronavirus
the nevada hospital association reports
82 percent of licensed hospital beds are
full but
the state seems optimistic about
hospitals abilities to handle the
situation
unlike earlier increases in the
hospitalization curve
hospitals are reporting sufficient
levels of personal protective equipment
and access to copin 19 testing has
significantly improved
new therapeutics also are available
during
including antibody infusion the state
expects to receive more than 164
thousand doses of the cobit 19 vaccine
this month
distribution though depends on a federal
review the first is scheduled
this thursday regarding the emergency
use authorization of
pfizer the other meeting is next week
for moderna
the outcomes will direct when nevadans
can then start accessing the vaccine
the state is also working to support
vulnerable communities impacted by the
virus
more on that initiative expected to
start this month coming up at 6